if you have something you want to say to
me and there's never an easy transition
out of uh out of a cancer diagnosis if
you have something you ought to say to
me you can leave a voicemail at 219 to
David P
um the Eggman actually called in we
could use a little levity the Eggman
called in and you know we did this story
yesterday about how Mike pillow says
he's suing the FBI he's suing everyone
and of course we all know how silly
these lawsuits are
Eggman says you know think about it if
your pillow's lawyer
or lawyers and you know he's got 300
million dollars you'll Sue whoever the
hell he wants you to sue Take the Money
and Run This is the eggman's perspective
on that
hey Dave imagine your pillows lawyer one
of his lawyers yeah you're at this
meeting at Hardee's or Arby's wherever
they go and he says to the FBI and we're
going to sue the president and the
lawyers are like how do we take this
man's money he has 30 million dollar
billion dollars worth of money but still
not do the ridiculous things he wants
how do we placate this man his lawyers
are telling him sure we'll sue the FBI
for you Mike write the check write the
check so his lawyers are getting loaded
probably laughing their asses off at his
insane request it may be God imagine the
waitress in that meeting is probably
smarter than all of them put together
Shalom yes Shalom of course and uh very
very soon we will be at Rosh Hashanah
egman and I uh Eggman uh Steve Eggman no
the Eggman
um yeah I think uh Eggman may be on to
something with Trump it's sort of the
opposite with Trump lawyers don't want
to represent him because he'll often
just never pay them with pillow assuming
pillow pays lawyers will probably be
willing to do whatever pillow wants sue
the FBI sure sue the Secret Service sue
the CIA yeah why not let's Sue everybody
uh if they can actually rack up money
from pillow Eggman May well be on to
something on today's bonus show we are
going to talk about the first in the
nation law protecting children's online
privacy the law is out of California we
will describe it
and we will discuss it for those of you
who uh listen to the first season of the
serial podcast
Adnan Syed has been released from prison
and what that means if you did not
listen to cereal the first season you
wouldn't know but I'll be like I will
explain all of it on today's bonus show
I think it'll be a really interesting
conversation and we are also going to
talk about the Illinois plan to end cash
bail and the uh and the criminalization
of poverty it is not a perfect law
it's not but we don't want to let the
perfect become the enemy of the good to
quote the great Ted Kennedy uh and we
will discuss that on today's bonus show
you can sign up at
joinpakman.com if you missed yesterday's
one day membership special and you would
like to take advantage just email in
info davidpackman.com ask for the coupon
code and it shall be sent to you so you
can take advantage of it we will see
everybody on the bonus show in a moment
or otherwise back here on the podcast
tomorrow